no llegan los deportes llega directo
aquí en France 24 y hoy en este espacio
nos vamos hasta Lima la capital de Perú
en donde se encuentra nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías Y es que
en medio de las protestas y bloqueos que
siguen en varias regiones del país y
tras la muerte de un nuevo manifestante
en Lima durante el fin de semana este
lunes el congreso debía debatir una
nueva propuesta de adelanto electoral un
debate que se aplazó Hasta mañana y que
llega tras el rechazo el pasado viernes
de otra propuesta de adelanto para
octubre Francisco la presidenta Dina
boluarte y el gobierno pidieron y
esperan que salga adelante el adelanto
electoral tienen apoyo suficientes en el
congreso Y por qué se ha decidido este
aplazamiento
Bueno en realidad las cosas van
retrasadas en el congreso la sesión de
hoy se vio iniciarse a las nueve de la
mañana y luego lo pospusieron para el
después del mediodía se inició el
mediodía se aprobó incluir el debate
sobre el adelanto de elecciones y luego
se hizo un receso se dijo que el receso
iba a durar tres horas esto se extendió
más de cinco horas y luego el presidente
del parlamento citó para la sesión de
mañana a partir de las once horas lo que
se sabe es que las bancadas al interior
del parlamento no se han puesto de
acuerdo para redactar un texto que se
esperaba que pudiera contar consenso de
todos los partidos políticos y
satisfacer en las demandas que ellos
piden la izquierda está pidiendo que se
incluya en la convocatoria a una
asamblea Constituyente que es rechazada
por la derecha que a su vez también
tiene posiciones muy marcadas unos
quieren que se que en las elecciones ese
2023 otros postulan a que sea el 2024 y
hay quienes señalan que las cosas deben
mantenerse cómo están y los comicios
deben de ser el 2026 porque hacer lo
contrario implicaría recortar el mandato
del Congreso Y eso consideran que atenta
contra la constitución política peruana
así las cosas va a estar muy difícil
porque Fuentes del parlamento me señalan
que no se pueden poner de acuerdo las
posiciones están muy distantes y va a
ser muy difícil que puedan aprobar la
reforma tal como ha propuesto la
presidenta de Adivina boluarte qué es lo
que tendría que suceder si hay este
rechazo la presidenta boluarte tendría
que enviar al Primer Ministro otaro al
parlamento hacer cuestión de confianza
para que aprueben la iniciativa pues
Francisco al tiempo y se reunió también
el consejo permanente de la Organización
de Estados Americanos para discutir esta
crisis en Perú Cuáles son los
principales puntos de la resolución a la
que han llegado
el consejo permanente de la Organización
de Estados Americanos le ha pedido al
Perú que aprueben elecciones lo más
pronto posible y que éstas sean justas
libres y transparentes el organismo
también ha mostrado su preocupación por
El excesivo uso de la fuerza con que las
autoridades han permitido que tanto la
policía como las fuerzas armadas
contengan las protestas en este país la
oea también le pide al gobierno de Dina
boluarte que despliegue acciones
efectivas para sancionar los actos de
violencia toda esta Norma llega
precisamente al país cuando continúan
las protestas para el día de mañana se
ha convocado otras acciones de lucha y
la policía y en las fuerzas armadas
están tratando de desbloquear las vías
nacionales que a esta hora están siendo
secuestradas por los protestantes en
diversos puntos del país